i don't consider myself a particularly  ethical person  but i'm fair  gucci  it was a name that sounded so sweet so  seductive god meet the family everybody  this is patricia and this is my family  they had it all  worth style  power  who wouldn't care for that  [Music]  but it's you my nephew i've been a gucci  all my life  it is an empire  you can help the family which is not  exciting and everybody knows it at least  it's my name sweetie  our name  sweetie  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  is what i say peace  this is not the woman's game  remember that  madness who does he think he is  it's time to take out the trash  [Music]  what game are you playing  for a family  [Music]  who does what  oh  don't  miss  [Music]  [Applause]  i don't consider myself a particularly  ethical person no but i am fair  i subscribe to  unconventional punishments  [Music]  [Music]  you